thrilled to have here on the program in
advance of his tight end summit and
all the news that is going on uh with
his son that appears to be doing just
fine
uh greg olson right here on the rich
eisen show how are you greg
doing right rich how are you doing i'm
doing better for talking to you how's
your son how's tj let's start off with
that
you know he's doing pretty good it's uh
it's almost
hard to believe uh you know he's about
two and a half weeks post
heart transplant and he's home and happy
and
eating and got to take him outside today
and kind of get him some fresh air and
take him a ride in the car and let him
get out and about a little bit
and he's uh it's just remarkable you
know
just to see him to see how far he's come
in such a short period of time
considering
you know about six weeks ago we were put
you know admitted into the icu and heart
failure
and told that we were going to embark on
this journey of
heart transplantation and we didn't know
what that time frame looked like or what
not to now be
sitting here at home and recovering and
all back together
it's pretty remarkable so what was your
father's day like
our my father's day was busy so for the
last month or so obviously we spent the
majority of our time in the hospital tj
was admitted
um like may 20th
and um so we were pretty much in the
hospital my wife and i would try to
bounce back and forth you know obviously
we have two other kids
that had events in school and
graduations and all that stuff going on
so we tried to do our best to
accommodate that but the majority of our
time was that
day uh with with with tj at the hospital
there was a you know just a bunch of
stuff we had to do getting ready for the
transplant meetings and whatnot so
i was actually fortunate enough on
wednesday we brought tj home and spent
wednesday and thursday
kind of getting him settled in back home
with with everybody and then thursday
my son my older son had a baseball
tournament in charleston south carolina
so since tj was home and recovered last
minute
um i was able to get up and take my son
down there and spent the weekend with
him and my dad
just the three of us at a baseball
tournament and then came home yesterday
and spent the rest of the day
all together for father's day so it was
all in all it was a great father's day
um felt a little more like back to
normal for me but it was uh
all in all it's just nice to have them
all back home together that's amazing
greg i mean
obviously that's something you we would
all sign for but you
certainly six weeks ago when you found
out that your your son
definitely needed a new heart which i
know you thought would be a possibility
at some point in time because
i know again that your your son was born
with
a defect correct because i know that you
and your wife have had a your foundation
focused
on what what your son tj has been
dealing with can you you want to give a
little bit more
information on that greg yeah of course
so and
yeah of course so in 2000 in 2012 tj was
born with a condition called hypoplastic
left heart syndrome and in essence what
it is
is he only has half of a heart um
he was born without a left ventricle uh
just never grew when he was
developing in utero and if left
untreated
you know you want you it's just a
hundred percent fatality so he had his
first open heart surgery to rework
uh the kind of the plumbing of his heart
when he was two days old
he had a second open heart surgery at
five months and then his
third and final stage of that kind of
reorientation of his heart
anatomy at two years old so he had three
open heart surgeries and then shortly
after that he had a pacemaker put in
and you know a handful of other smaller
procedures so he's lived
he lived eight years with that anatomy
um
and we always knew like you said that
there was the possibility of that single
ventricle what they call it
um failing and that's in essence what
happened to his we were hoping it would
last a little longer
but for him it lasted eight years and
you know he was deemed to be in heart
failure when we brought him into the
hospital
admitted into the icu and started the
process department you know
of heart transplant so this is something
we've dealt with since the night he was
born
we knew prior to him being born that he
would have this condition
and that this would be a you know a long
journey for him so
we have had uh we've had a lot of nights
in the hospital we've had a lot of
surgeries and consultations with doctors
but you know we're just so thankful for
the children's hospital here in the dean
children's we do a lot of charitable
work with them we just built a new heart
center with them
through our foundation the hardest yard
so we uh we've been living this journey
for about nine years now
so um pardon me for asking uh uh a
particularly personal question but i'm
i'm i'm wondering do you do you know
whose heart is in your
your son's chest right now greg no it's
a great question it's a great question
and i'll tell you the
the the hardest part of this entire
journey i think for my wife kara and i
as we went through you know probably
about five or six days of
pretty significant consultation with the
transplant team
um every aspect of it you know from the
mental health component of it to the
financial component of it to the actual
medical
process to the transplant pro all you
know everything just there's a million
people you sit down within consult
before they
finally allow you to be listed on the
transplant list
one of the hardest things to wrap your
head around is you know the gift of life
that
now sits in my son and allows him to be
home with his brother and sister
came as a result of someone else's
tragedy and right now
that's unfortunately that's
the only way that this can can go on you
know there's a lot of research out there
and a lot of studies being done as we
speak about the process of being able to
grow your own tissue and grow your own
organs so that it didn't have to be
reliant on someone else's passing but
as we stand here today that's just the
way heart heart donor
the heart donation process works and um
but no we they are not allowed to tell
us any of the information we don't even
know what center it came from we don't
know the
circumstances of what happened the age
we don't know anything
um there is a process through the the
organ procurement company called unos
which is like the national body that
oversees the process
they do have a pro uh a way that the
recipient family can
write a letter to the donor family and
and then the balls in their court
whether or not they want to
engage with us to share more information
but
i'm sure at some point that'll be
something that we we get into but as we
stand here today
we don't know we don't know anything
about the situation
well in terms of what we know greg olsen
about the situation a lot of it is
because you and your wife have been so
sharing and um posting videos of tj
and what he what he looks like and
sounds like it's just
it really is a beautiful thing greg and
um you know also his siblings as well
being there where he's he's he's talking
to them about
hey we have an offer for a heart
transplant and seeing their reaction and
giving him
a hug and just seeing tj just smiling
like he basically told him he got a good
grade in school you know and i i
i my wife and i as we've you know gone
through this
parenting gauntlet uh which it is
sometimes um when when when my kid has
our children have had something not
nearly as serious obviously as this but
it is something that requires uh a
stitch
or something that does require uh
preparing the child for something
we were always told it's gonna hurt you
more than the kid you know it's gonna
affect you more than the kid
how is your son handling all this and
and and providing
you and your wife even comfort with the
way that he might be
handling it i'll tell you what he uh he
handled it
you you just hit the nail on the head it
was a thousand times more stressful and
agonizing and
i think my wife and i had way more
sleepless nights through this process
than he did
he was content being in the hospital
walking around with his
iv bag and his backpack playing air
hockey in the
in the you know child's life room and
building a wooden
like he every day that we spent there
with him whoever spent the day or the
night with him
it was an awesome day to him and his
outlook on that in life that's
anyone who knows tj like that's him
he makes the most of everything
he doesn't have any like you know
doesn't have any fomo right like we joke
like tj's like the non-fombo like he
doesn't fear
all right the other kids are at a
baseball game and i had to stay home
that's okay i hope they win you know
like that's his attitude and
we always say like he was put in this
situation
because he's one of probably our only
kid and one of few kids who has the
outlook and the mental outlook to to be
able to take it
as best in stride as possible and
whether this has caused him to have that
attitude or his attitude
was there to begin with it's hard to say
but he's
he's handled this with way more grace
and way more optimism he never felt
sorry for himself he never
felt like life was unfair he never he
never looked at it from the negative
and it's a big reason they told us going
in the mental health
component they spent a lot of time with
tj and child psychologists and
and the family preparing him and i think
the mental
component of it is why he has had such a
good recovery because he never
once felt sorry for himself or got down
on himself
and i you know we all know his brain
your brain controls so much of your
outlook and
for him it's a perfect example of that
amazing craig
just truly amazing and i just love the
fact that you and i are talking with an
outcome that
that has turned out to be um looking the
way that it looks and
seeing seeing him smiling and your wife
and you and your wife smiling and
you know i know it's sometimes it's
tough to make a transition
uh in in this business as you know now
that you're in the the world of tv
but uh i'm glad that a lot of this stuff
appears to be
on the straight and narrow and moving
forward just in time for
a big week that i know this is big for
you and
your colleagues your tight end summit we
talked about it with kittle
i want to get kelsey on this program
because you know i'm i'm all about
tight ends as well uh as kickers you
know because you guys sometimes
you know i don't mean to lump you all
together but sometimes there is a lack
of respect for this position
it's true and you have your own day now
thanks to kittle um
but yeah so correct you you will be
there everything's all settled for you
to be
present at this uh this this nashville
based summit
for tight ends going down this week yep
so originally so
one thing you know obviously when things
went i had to kind of take a back seat
but um
you know over the last few weeks as
things kind of progressed and moved
forward here at home and
he's home and settled um yeah i'll be
able to go um
fly down wednesday night actually
believe it or not the
one of our major sponsors good plug here
but it's actually a good transition
uh one of our major sponsors body armor
was nice enough to
help me arrange transportation when
things were going
sideways and things were busy here if i
wanted to get down they helped arrange
transportation to get down there they
were one of the first people to
jump on board to help us put on this
awesome event so
i'm personally and at the camp super
thankful for them to
help us put this on but yes we have
about 50 we have about 50 nfl tight ends
coming down to nashville
um wednesday thursday friday of this
week
uh we're putting them up in the hotel we
got meetings workouts
we're going to work out on the field
we're going to work out in the classroom
we're going to have presentations
we're going to have a little fun at
night we're going to go out and you know
have some dinner and have everyone in
and for three days we're just going to
focus on
tight ends you know we're going to dive
into everything that makes
tight ends unique and special we're
going to have you know the kittles and
the kelseys and the mercedes-lewis and
guys who've really done
aspects of the game at a really high
level make these cool presentations and
have some classroom time so i think
you know i think 50 guys all different
backgrounds all different
experience levels it's going to be as
unique
an event as i've ever been a part of no
kidding
so uh last we checked with kittle he he
said that there
was up in the air in terms of the
syllabus but you're all like this is all
settled you got the whole
you got powerpoints you got meetings you
got you got
camaraderie you got this whole thing
working what do you hope to achieve from
this
greg olsen what's uh what's the end
result here i think i think the biggest
thing i think so much
you know there's quarterback camps and
you know there's other positions that
a lot of the time steal a lot of the
attention but i think as we've seen over
the last decade or so
you know the evolution of the tight end
has become such a
prominent role not you know for for the
team of course but
just throughout the league you know
there's a lot of big personalities tight
ends are finally
at the point where you know they're
along the lines of the star quarterbacks
you know kittle and kelsey and those
guys i mean they're
they're on the same level as you know
the cam newtons and the russell wilsons
and the odell beckhams and you know
those guys and that
hasn't always been like that and you
know it's just a position that a lot of
guys take a lot of pride in i think it's
a position that
internally around the nfl is very highly
valued
but i don't know if necessarily everyone
truly appreciates it so i think
to get guys who know what it's like and
want to continue to to build that
you know build that platform of what the
position brings um
we could have had 75 people rich i mean
with the amount of guys who reached out
to us and we had
college coaches asking if they could
attend and bring their
bring their kids and we had people from
all over the section
that we had we had to cut it at some
point say you know we got to keep this
for nfl guys
you got to try to keep it at 50 you know
because we're
you know wednesday night we're going to
have a you know a little get-together
dinner kickoff party at the
at hotel and you know you start putting
50 guys up in hotel rooms
i mean it gets hard you know this is a
uh
you know to be able to do all this for
everybody as nice as kelsey and kittle
and myself are you know it's
not cheap but um you know we're we've
got some awesome sponsors who jumped in
jumped in on this i already mentioned
you know body armor and bridgestone is
local
um and levi's and we got some really
cool sponsors that came in and said hey
we'll help you flip the bill on giving
these guys this experience
and then on the back end all the
remaining money we're going to give to
the national boys and girls club we're
going to have a bunch of their kids over
for a free football camp on thursday
afternoon in the middle of our session
and
and then all the rest of the proceeds
are going to be given to various
you know children's charities both in
nashville and throughout the country so
at the same time putting on a cool event
we'll be able to help a lot of
a lot of good organizations as a result
of the sponsors that have jumped on
board
what about gronk is he coming i know i'm
getting into some territory here
who's here who's not but is gronk coming
we invited him
uh he said he was going to try to make
it he's not as of now he's not one of
our confirmed
come on um he's not but but we got some
real i mean we got
you know the who's who list i mean
obviously besides we got darren waller
um we got you know hurts is coming and
hooper and obviously we got kelsey and
kittle we got uh
kyle pitts there we got some young guys
coming in so we
you know we got we got a pretty good
group and
we invited gronk we'd love him to join
us he's a busy man
he's a busy man well here's another one
what about tebow
to tebow is he is he coming i don't
think tebow's coming i think i think our
again when we started talking about how
do we control this you know how do we
make this not a hundred guys
we had at some point our point was like
let's try to get guys who
been a part of the position have had a
little background on a roster you know
try to
build some guidelines now listen if
tebow wants to continue to develop as a
tight end which
knowing his personality and the type of
guy he is i'm sure he's going to do
everything a billion miles an hour
and this time next year he's still kind
of chasing that transition and he's on a
roster wants to come
we'd love to have him you know i have
nothing but
respect for him and i hope he does
awesome you know but
you know we're trying to accommodate
young guys and old guys alike and
the numbers sometimes get a little tough
what what if uh
what if um you know are you gonna have
like a a seminar
on uh on making yourself a wide receiver
when it comes time to be classified as a
franchise
tag player or something like that or you
know are we gonna
we're gonna have something like that
like next level type 3d chess
greg what do you think jimmy when i
remember when jimmy went through that
with with new orleans years back yeah
it's the you know we we were joking
about it on a call the other night
with with george you know we said you
know they want us to block the guy the
tackle blocks and run routes on the guy
the receiver block
runs routes against and pay us you know
and
you know it's kind of the running joke
of tight ends in the league but uh
that's part of what makes the position
special we understand that and we
embrace that
and uh we're gonna make the most of it
i'm fired up for you greg
um enjoy it enjoy that time enjoy the
time
and i do want to say this too i do want
to say this too
um and i think you will echo the
sentiments easily but i'll say this
anyway
um i know it was just father's day but
i'm doing the math in my head
about when you found out that your son
needed
a transplant your wife
cara must have had a heck of a mother's
day and i hope that next year her
mother's day is like your father's day
greg well i appreciate that and i hope i
hope so too she'd if anyone deserves it
she's uh she's the rock she's she's
unbelievable
she's she handled things as well as i
could ever imagine a mother handling
what she's been through for nine years
so i
i wish nothing more than that and we're
gonna try to give her
a lot of good days between now and then
please send her my best and
your entire family and happy father's
day greg olsen
happy father's day appreciate it rich
same to you buddy i always enjoy coming
on thanks so much you're the best let's
have you back on later on in the summer
we'll talk football when you're getting
started uh
set uh to start your broadcasting career
thanks for the call would love it
look forward to it right back at you
that's greg olson everybody